على مسافه تزيد عن الكيلومترات صفا طويل
من السيارات يمتد عند اطراف مدينه خرسانه
هذه الاخيره باتت هدفا دائما للقذف الروسي
منذ تحريرها قبل اسبوعين
لا يمكننا ان نفعل غير ذلك بعد ثلاثه او
اربعه ايام
بدا القصف العنيف قتل وجورح كثير من الناس
الروس يستهدفون وسط المدينه والمنازل وكل
شيء
لا يمكننا البقاء هنا
شهدت المدينه يوم الجمعه اعنف قصف جوي راح
ضحيته 15 مدنيا السلطات لاوكرانيه عقله
المستشفيات من المرضى تحسبا لاي قذف محتمل
اما الحل بالنسبه للكثير من السكان هنا
فهو النزوح الجماعي
اهداف محدده
تستهدفون مواقع عسكريه فقط
عروس يستهدفون ايضا البنيه التحتيه
للطاقات تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه انها
اعاده الكهرباء ومحطات المياه الى العمل
رغم الاضرار الجسيمه